in a closed session on monday the
eastern based parliament in tulbruck
said it passed a vote of no confidence
in the inter immunity government
but now there are questions about the
transparency of the vote and if it was
even legal
foreign
after reaching quorum for today's
session with 113 mps present a vote of
no confidence was carried out with 89
mps voting to pull confidence from the
unity government the unity government
will continue its work as a caretaker
government
muhammad rayet is an mp he says that for
a no confidence vote to be legal at
least 120 mps must vote for it to be
official
what we saw today was a group of mps who
agreed to carry out a vote they entered
the hall and within minutes announced
that 89 mps voted to pull confidence
from the government there wasn't any
information on who voted how many voted
against and who abstained
the government of national unity came to
power in march it followed a long and
challenging political settlement helped
by the united nations it was tasked with
leading the country until nationwide
elections can take place in december
the move by the parliament to vote on a
no-confidence motion is not in libya's
interest the parliamentary government
should be cooperating and intensifying
their efforts to provide the right
conditions for holding elections
after years of conflict libyans were
beginning to feel hopeful that things
were getting better but now with clear
signs of political divisions emerging
that feeling may start to fade away and
put into question if elections can be
held as scheduled malik trainer al
jazeera tripoli